I am so honored and delighted that this
man knows my name and he's going to be
one of the guest on our podcast and I
please welcome Guillermo del Toro now
I would like to as as Guerra Mo's taken
scene I want to I want you to know
people are passing out tickets this is
part of a giveaway we're doing a Google
VR giveaway so that you can check out
you're going to get 50,000 of these are
being distributed and then there's very
specific experiences from Warcraft
crimson peak and Pak Ram when you go
over to the legendary booth so you can
redeem those can I can I ask a favor
when Tom Hiddleston comes out ignore him
yeah that's Tony Dona plot nothing it's
impossible nothing do nothing
he's hypnotic so tell let's let's just
really quickly talk before we show some
footage a little bit about crimson peak
and why you wanted to make it and why
you thought it was important to to tell
well I I wanted to create a really
classical lush lavish gothic romance you
know it hasn't been done in a while and
it's there always female centric movies
that have very strong protagonist I have
two daughters that are incredibly strong
and and my wife is my high school
sweetheart who's incredibly strong and
and I really think that many times in
some of these movies the girl ends up
being a damsel in distress and I wanted
to create a tale that was a classical
Gothic romance don't expect a
reinvention when at the end turns out
that the house was a spaceship and it
was experiment about nothing or it's all
a studio and they're shooting a TV show
nothing it's a straight gothic romance
but when certain twists are a little
more gender liberating shall we say and
there they are they are a little more
about being yourself and stuff like that
but that we stop I'm incredibly
conscious about this we do daughters we
are we live in a world that is a there
is a secret gender war and we we have to
assist or utilities or duty to take
these grades honors and great forms and
retell them a little in that conscious
of them
excellent that said I wanted to be scary
and notice I don't use that word that
Thomas said I don't
what were you control I have huge
control and I wanted to be scary and I
wanted it to be gorgeous and I think is
a movie it's one of my three favorite
movies are gone and is in my opinion you
don't have to agree is the most
beautiful movie I have made esta época
Madre so let's why do we show a clip
from this and then we'll have a little
announcement about something from the
trailer after you guys see it let's do
that and then they warn you for those
that don't like spoilers there are
spoilers what the damn I'm not gonna say
it let's now meet the cast of Crispin
crimson peak I think you're very excited
to see Mia Wasikowska Tom Nelson Jessica
the long walk all the way across
ah welcome please thank you very much
that is his life oh my god I always say
that if they found him grinding poppies
in an alley they will go all puppies
solid ice I know dude so um you guys
this is the first peak that you've seen
at the trailer do you want to make an
announcement about the Allerdale Hall
well we aren't we are creating an
experience at Halloween Horror Nights at
Universal so all of you that live in
California or partake I'll see you there
it's gonna be terrifying I'm cold
excellent me let's start with you what
can you tell us about your character and
what was what was the experience like
being on set I mean it's everything's it
the environment was so immersive yeah
I've never been on a set like this
before it was the most beautifully
created mansion and the detail is just
so incredible and um yeah I've never
been on a set like that before it was
amazing yeah I know backstage I was
talking to Tom about what we were gonna
talk about her and he goes I want to
just throw it to the fans I would rather
just have the fans ask questions because
everything he says makes your heart melt
so uh we're gonna open up the floor to
fan questions right now and you guys can
ask the panel whatever it is that you
want to know that's a great accent it
does everything about him yes hi what
are you okay yeah okay what's your name
uh Joe and what's your question I'm a
cosmos I know that builders size is set
sir so I want to know which part of sets
do guys like most oh that's a really
good question
what did you say which part of the set
do guys like most yeah yes are up on
that that's okay just lean closer to the
microphone we can't we can't really hear
you that which part of sad do
guys like which part on set you guys
like most like what's your favorite part
of this is it the acting or is it this
what do you love of the physical set you
mean yeah oh yeah katal yeah I I
personally I the Great Hall it I found
just jaw-dropping because you have to
understand this they this is the house
that the Sharps living is in Cumberland
in the north of England and the house
was built on a soundstage in Toronto and
when I walked in for the first time it
was just breathtaking because it was on
three or four storeys with a working
elevator and and if you actually trod on
the floorboards the clay which is
underneath the house would seep across
the floor is the most extraordinary
place the most extraordinary have ever
seen and I was actually very sad when
they had to tear it down that's what
they do is very sad I like the bathroom
I mean it sounds horrible but the
bathroom is gorgeous yeah that's very
important just a lot for the reasons you
think I feel like some of the reasons we
think well yes I do
I like I mean maybe it's a bit
possessive but I really liked Lucille's
bedroom and every corner of that room
was filled with something that I can't
really explain it cuz it's all spoilers
but it was so so beautiful and it's
photographed beautifully
I mean what was her favorite part about
making the crimson peak um probably just
you know being able to work with gamo
and and the cast who was so fantastic
and I'm was new to the genre and to the
concept of horror or and I found
Guillermo gave me a copy of Frankenstein
and there was an introduction to the
book that he wrote and it was like sort
of an education in in you know why it's
an important thing and how we learn
about ourselves through our fears and so
it was kind of amazing to have Guillermo
as a guide in this new
you world and it's really cool excellent
let's uh what is your name my name is
Katie and what's your question my
questions for Tom I want to know from
prett from your perspective how is mr.
del Toro different from the art
directors you've worked with
I mean what's unique about him well the
first thing to say is that we all got
given these extraordinary character
biographies when he received the script
and it was a 10-page life story maybe
even it was 50 in a comment but it was
the most incredible document with my
star sign and my date of birth and the
secrets that I don't want to tell anyone
and what I like and what I don't like
and a horrible time I had with my armed
when I was 13 in Whitehaven and and and
that kind of detail is what we should
all do with every character we play and
I just had the best time with Gemma we
had gamma has an enormous imagination
and getting to live inside that
imagination with all of his detail and
and rigor and precision was a huge
pleasure and I've never been teased so
much I set by another director but I
liked it well if we're like twins
yeah like twins huh like the Danny
DeVito so give me like the movie twins
I'm Danny DeVito
that make me
Ahnold like yes yeah hi what's your name
I'm Darcy and what's your question Darcy
okay so this is for Guillermo and for
Tom um ever since I saw this one
interview I was really curious what was
the difference between the original
version of Thomas Sharpe and the one
that was rewritten after Benedict struck
from the cast mm-hmm well the first
thing you do is when you write a
screenplay and then you have a first
second third draft whenever you go out
with the screenplay then what I do is I
then work with the actors I generate
these biographies that are about 10
pages give it to them and then we sit
down and do what it's called table work
and what we do is with
is cause the biography with the pages
what they like what they don't like and
we go through a beautiful fun discovery
process we say oh I would do these
figures of that and I would not do this
because of that and you kind of then
come out of those meetings supercharged
you go back and input all that visually
or audio-visual into the set design into
the way you're designing the sound or in
pieces of dialogue and staging and but
ultimately all of it is fed into it the
movie as a Jessica was saying
Lucille's bedroom for example came out
entirely of these discussions and every
single piece in there tells you a little
bit about her I say that I write the
movies on paper but really they get
written on film and and if you pay
attention in my movies if you are
watching every detail every detail
should add up to that so it changes a
lot so Thomas Sharpe was on every other
part was tailored to the actor doing it
now is Thomas turn excellent and then
just sort of branching over to Jessica
what were some things that you took away
or what were some things that you liked
about your character that you can share
I like a lot about my character I love
her she actually absolutely breaks my
heart what I love about her is that
she's fiercely loyal and um and she acts
out of love to receive love and her way
to give and receive love most of that
came from working with Guillermo and
reading the biography he sent me and
we'd be on set together working on a
scene and the biography the secrets of
who Lucille was would inform the
decisions made in the scene and
sometimes new scenes would pop up
Lucille's bedroom would pop up we had a
great rehearsal with Tom in London and
we read our biographies for each other
but I did ask I said please don't read
anything that you wouldn't want your
sister to know
oh that's great so I made sure that I
kept my secrets and we all kept theirs
yeah we don't share the biographies and
the actors don't share them so they can
keep secrets from each other you know
and and that that is actually a fun game
it's also it's interesting the film is
so much about secrets um and I think you
know all of us in our lives we will try
and live in the present we live in the
here and now but we are we are formed by
the past and the things we did the
things that were done to us
and every character in this film is is
so it's almost is either way down or
liberated by what's happened in the past
and the house itself is the path is the
past and in witness to what happened in
that house it's or everything it heard
everything and I think I think the
exciting tension in the film is that
it's um every character is struggling to
create their own destiny um I think
that's fun that's nightly realtor for
one more question I think that's you yes
I'm done Anna first I wanted to thank
Jessica and Mia for portraying such
strong multifaceted characters and I
wanted to thank Tom and Guillermo for
just supporting them and giving them
that spotlight but the question yeah I'm
sorry
um over the course of filming the movie
what was the most creatively or
emotionally challenging part of that for
you uh the last act of the film is an
emotional roller coaster that is that it
exists at a very intense pitch and we
all have to kind of hold hands and
battle through it because it's it's a it
can you know it can take it out of your
Sunday's but I loved living I mean I
think most actors become actors because
they're fascinated by extremity they're
fascinated by what happens when people
are tested by physical psychological or
emotional challenges they have to
become and I personally find the last 45
minutes of this film is headlong and
thrilling and there's twist after twist
and you don't know where it's gonna go
and um you know had it was a very
satisfying challenge to overcome
excellent
so before we let you guys go gear but
you have one thing that you want to say
to people about this movie that you want
them to take away from Hall H to go see
it when it comes out in October of this
year I think this is the first time that
I felt really empowered by the support
of legendary and Universal - - with
mimic I decided in 97 I said I'm gonna
do my more young movies in America you
know things that I loved as a kid and
stuff like that but I'm gonna keep my
more adult and hardcore stuff for my
European or spanish-language films and
this is the first time that I ventured
into this early on we decided it needed
to be our it needed to be complex and I
secretly was hoping I hope the other
show never drops I hope we never have to
cross that bridge where they say well
yes we remember we said it could be our
but this is too much or this is blah
blah blah and it never happened so I'm
very very happy to say that I felt for
the first time completely free to make
an adult movie in the English language
and I hope you guys enjoy the hell out
of it I would say hell yeah Ryan please
October 16 2015 Gamma Delta Mia
Wasikowska Tom Hiddleston Jessica
Chastain crimson peak
excellence there they go
and people are rushing out cards are
being loaded like if anyone should be
allowed to say the F word in hall way it
should be Jer mo we should just change
this to Hall F and then just good
I love you all too
uh just so you know you're all pregnant
now that's how it works
enjoy your babies enjoy your hit ladies
you